you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is another
endgame study this one here composed by
D Joseph and published in 1922 it's
white to move if you'd like to go ahead
pause the video set up this position on
one of your own boards if you like see
we can come up with try and find the
best continuation for white okay the
solution to this one is one that'll draw
our attention to certain endgame draws
some interesting endgame draws as well
as defensive resources by way of
stalemate and also a little bit of chess
triangulation the first move of this
winning continuation is to promote to a
queen black does the same and it's
important to note taking the queen is
not best
this is stalemate I can do better and
what white wants do now is stay on this
eighth rank so that white is in a
position to move the King out of the way
and it'll end up as discovered check and
mate so which of these three squares
should the Queen go to is now the big
question playing 2ei once you've
identified that the Queen should be
going to one of these three and that
taking the Queen is not best try and
find the differences between these three
playing the e8 is not best because it
allows Queen g7 and the king is not able
to move out of the Queen's way to
deliver that discovered check and mate
and if you try let's say this square
here that's not working either because
it allows this defensive resource Queen
a3 yet again she's shouldn't be taken
because it be stalemate and she's also
now in a position to play to d6 next so
if the Queen tries to go to one of these
three squares let's say here that's
worst of all this is allowing in fact
black to win with Queen d6 the Queen s
to block pawn is taken the Queen's are
traded in black wins the trick here is
that after promoting you play to g8 you
just go one
step what you can't stop the king from
playing to one of these two giving a
check or playing here there's just not a
move you could play a successful move
you could play with the black Queen that
will stop the King from going to one of
these two to deliver a discovered check
and mate so you need to try Queen a two
similar idea that again still being
stalemate however after Queen a two only
at this point only after we have forced
the Queen up one square do we make use
of EI and things are a bit different now
because after Queen a4 well let me first
point out the Queen once the once the
White Queen has arrived on ei the black
Queen is not able to make use of this
seventh-ranked successfully to cut the
King off after Queen a for this now
allows this idea of a chest
triangulation Queenie five width check
the King goes to the corner and now we
go back to that promotion square we did
a little bit of chess triangulation
there with the Queen there's no longer
due to the king being in this corner
square there's no longer this idea of
stalemate
if black goes to a one we can now take
the Queen with check and give mate next
so with this little chess triangulation
now black is completely gone
Queen to d1 check pick your favourite
square to go to King here the Queen has
to block and that's me so the main point
here is to promote to a queen make use
of the correct square you need to try
and find the differences between each of
those three Queen's g8 and only after
Queen a to do we make use of EI t' and
then do this little chess triangulation
giving check and going back in the
corner and mate will follow soon
thereafter now one interesting question
I had when trying to solve this myself
was well if I promote to a queen and
they promote to a queen I saw that I
couldn't take so one question I had well
was well what about promoting to let's
say a bishop and after black let's say
promotes
to whatever we just take that piece now
it won't be stalemate however this is an
own drawn ending we cannot win despite
being up this minor piece after the king
goes here in fact the king simply
bounces back and forth the defending
side bounces to aid and b8 the king
could never approach this pawn he can
never even put himself in a position to
attack that black pawn because it'll be
stalemate and if this square is ever
guarded by the bishop this is stalemate
so you just cannot win this position and
this may raise another interesting
question which is to say well can white
win if it is a light square bishop well
the answer to that is also no let me
just show that it could be a little bit
more tricky but let me put this on board
making some dummy moves here to get a
light square bishop on board if we're
working with the light square bishop
this too is a draw but it's maybe a
little bit more tricky or involved
because the bishop can it leads to tack
this pawn or capture that pawn for
example let's say after the king goes
here we could have bishop here and white
could try some sneaky stuff like this
with Bishop a6 and if black takes then
white will win because he's able to push
through like so but all black does is
simply not take the bishop and plays
here and you're just not going to be
able to win and one other try would be
let's say to play here once again you
don't take because of this and you're
pushing through as white so what do you
do is black after remove like this
simply King to b8 and Bishop takes pawn
this will be a draw and if King here now
we take the Bishop after King takes pawn
this will be a draw black now taking
opposition and stalemate or black
capturing the pawn on the next move will
occur so some interesting things of
course to take away from this one this
idea of certain endgame drawers
regardless of what color Bishop is on
board whether it's a dark square bishop
or a light square bishop this will be a
drawn position when we have
the defending side with their night
pawns still on is home square and this
Ram structure does not matter what color
complex the bishop is on this is a known
drawn position for as long as the
defending sides King is in that corner
where that Knight pawn is and also this
the defense of resources by way of
stalemate and lastly this little bit of
a chest triangulation to cap it off so
an interesting endgame that I came
across and feel free to share what your
thoughts are on this one and I'll catch
you in the next video take care bye
you